una chica puede sentirse más masculina
pero no significa que no es una chica es
decir que yo nací hombre biológicamente
dices que soy 100% hombre bueno tú
hiciste una transición
jubilee
middle ground
y
reunimos a personas y género y
transgénero para que compartieran sus
ideas sobre sus diferencias y
similitudes
hola mi nombre es quite el amor soy
escritora creo en dios y que nos diseñó
con un propósito y quien esa hermosa
historia se encuentra en nuestro adn
hola mi nombre es natalie soy agente de
bienes raíces y estoy encantada de
compartir con ustedes hola a todos me
llamo rebeca soy estudiante y me siento
muy halagada de poder compartir ideas
con ustedes y saber lo que piensan hola
mi nombre es rory y mi género es no
binario me gusta usar pronombres
neutrales qué tal me llamo set in y soy
una mujer transgénero soy maquilladora
en televisión y películas mi nombre es
marcos y me identifico como un hombre
transgénero y estoy muy emocionado por
charlar con ustedes
hombres y mujeres deben ser tratados por
igual
la razón por la que creo que hombres y
mujeres deben ser tratados por igual es
que ambos somos miembros activos de la
sociedad ciudadanos y esas cosas exacto
no es que yo piense que no hay géneros
pero creo que las personas jóvenes deben
sentirse en la capacidad de explorarse a
sí mismos y tomar decisiones
estoy de acuerdo en muchos de los puntos
que ustedes tocaron y creo que hay
muchas similitudes entre hombres y
mujeres mientras crecen y creo que un
niño debe crecer en un ambiente de amor
y respeto pero necesita estar balanceado
y por las características de hombres y
mujeres donde las mujeres
usualmente somos más maternales y el
hombre se preocupa un poco más por lo
que significa ser hombre como proveo a
mi familia que es lo que significa ser
el pilar de tu hogar y por eso pienso
que el hombre es la cabeza del hogar
crecí siendo un poco masculina y estoy
muy muy conectada con mi lado masculino
y mi lado femenino me siento en un 50/50
yo siento que nuestra sociedad actual
cuando una chica se siente algo
masculina o le gustan cosas que pueden
ser masculinas ella está motivada a
pensar quizás debía haber nacido hombre
pero para mí es como que solo está
interesada en algunas cosas que los
chicos usualmente hacer y eso está bien
puede ser una chica interesada en cosas
de hombre y que tu identidad permanezca
intacta sí bueno siguiendo la corriente
de lo que estás diciendo cuando yo era
una niña siempre quise comprar en la
sección de hombres por supuesto mi
familia estaba completamente en
desacuerdo vengo de una familia muy
religiosa y de hecho me gusta el hecho
de ser cristiano pero mi familia uso el
hecho de que yo era un poco masculina
para tachar una posibilidad de minimizar
el hecho de que yo no me sentía como una
chica no me gustaba hacerlo como dijiste
muchas veces hay mujeres que
genuinamente son un poco masculinas pero
en mi caso no no fue así y creo que es
súper difícil para los padres hacer
estas distinciones porque no somos niños
pequeños es muy difícil expresar
realmente cómo lo sentimos especialmente
cuando tienes como no sé ocho años y no
tienes la menor idea de lo que es
transgénero yo no sabía nada eso eso es
lo que realmente importa a esa edad no
deberías saberlo sabes no estás
preparado para experimentarlo apuntó
solo hay dos géneros
tu adn será el mismo desde que naces
hasta que te mueras y no importa cómo te
vistas o todas las hormonas que quieras
tomar serás un hombre o una mujer tienes
todos esos cromo socios en tu cuerpo hay
cosas que se van a mantener intactas y
ser así durante toda tu vida debemos
aceptar la realidad y mantenernos ahí
porque si no lo haces comienzas a
odiarte
yo de verdad quería ser normal no había
nada en este mundo que hubiese querido
más que ser normal y que es ser normal
hacerlo ese es el problema el problema
es que eso no existe y yo realmente me
esforcé por estar de un género neutral a
otro pero no funcionó finalmente
encontré un lugar donde me siento bien
quizás muchas personas dicen que no se
puede estar en el medio pero
en el medio y sé que las personas que
realmente me aman son capaces de ver eso
ahora me es
muy difícil pensar que haya sólo dos
cómo podría ser eso posible si hay un
espectro de lo que es femenino o
masculino puedes escoger uno bueno es
que lo que decimos es que una chica
pueda sentirse como más más y más
masculina no significa que no sea una
chica es el espectro pero hay
definitivamente dos polos es decir bien
que yo nací hombre biológicamente dices
que soy 100% hombre bueno tú hiciste una
transición quiere decir que no te
severos éticamente naciste como es decir
que soy 100% mujer para ser honesta y
decir lo que siento usando tu cromosoma
debo decir que eres 100% hombre o no
bien se ha de actuar solo lo que yo
pienso eres un 100% de lo que quiere
hacer lo que pasa es como deseo por ti
eso no significa que yo deba estar en un
solo lado del espectro no le gusta diosa
de uno o el otro lo que podemos llamar
significa mente eres uno de los dos y
siempre serás un hombre
típicamente puedes expresarte como
quieras como desees que te vea el mundo
y con suerte el mundo te aceptará por lo
que quieres y por quién eres pero aún
sigue estando ahí el espectro no hay
tanta gente trans en este mundo como
para que eso sea así además en los
ángeles hay muchas personas trajeron no
nos ven
el tratado del 100% es verdad ustedes
chicas en toda su vida seguro no saben
cuántas personas han conocido que son
trans la razón por la que no lo ven es
porque los trans no quieren ser vistos
en centroamérica no existen las mismas
posibilidades y leyes que hay en
california es cómo voy a ocultarme y
mentir para no sé salvar mi vida o algo
así tengo derecho a usar el baño que he
decidido por mi identidad de género
totalmente de acuerdo
este es uno de los puntos en que entro
en disyuntiva yo por un lado con todo mi
corazón respeto a lo que cada quien
quiere hacer y hacer con su vida saben
pero por otro lado si tengo una hija
y tú no has completado tu transición no
quisieras que fuera expuesta a su
trampero no tan pronto no tan pronto yo
de esa forma han pensado alguna vez cómo
se siente esa persona todo el miedo que
puede sentir al ser juzgado sólo por
estar ahí antes de mi transición estaba
muy confundida sobre lo que quería hacer
y lo que iba a hacer con mi vida fue muy
difícil decidí usar el baño de mujeres
porque no me sentía segura en el de
hombres y supe que fue una buena
decisión debes ser muy valiente y la
gente no entiende eso son marcas de por
vida entiendo completamente y estoy de
acuerdo en que vayas a donde te sientas
cómoda pero quiero poner un límite al
hecho de que llegará el día en que los
baños estén abiertos a todo el mundo me
gusta ese punto he estado en gimnasios
donde están los baños y afuera hay un
lugar para cambiarse es difícil porque
cuando las reglas empiezan a ser
demasiado flexibles veremos a hombres
entrando al vestidor de damas que no
sean trans y si alguien lo cuestiona él
podría decir es que hoy me siento que
son mujeres
y eso me preocupa un poco es interesante
ver cómo nos preocupamos con los hombres
trans en los baños cuando dejamos a un
lado el hecho de que la mayoría de los
hombres son depredadores y que tenemos
miedo de los depredadores no solo como
mujeres trans sino en general tal vez si
hubiesen baños de género neutral quiero
decir no todos pero que algunos si
fuesen de género neutral nos sentiríamos
más seguros estoy de acuerdo
el género no debería definirse por los
sentimientos
cuando me dicen saben que no nos
definimos al nacer y que yo decido lo
que soy lo siento no tiene sentido para
mí yo creo que primero nace si eres
hombre o mujer creo que tu género no
debe estar basado en tus sentimientos ya
que cambiamos de parecer muchas veces no
todos lo hacen pero la mayoría de la
gente lo hace mientras crece
dijeron la palabra decidir yo no esperé
hasta los 18 años para decir hoy seré un
hombre
solo tome una decisión incluso yo no
quería ser un hombre transgénero la
decisión que tome fue ser totalmente
auténtico para ser feliz estaba entre
ser feliz o cometer suicidio
eventualmente la cosa con el género es
que tú no lo decides eso se va
desarrollando con el tiempo es algo
fluido y no lo estoy negando nació
hombre y no lo niego pero mis documentos
dicen que soy mujer porque es así como
me siento eso soy una cosa que quisiera
saber crecieron en una familia
conservadora tuvieron la oportunidad de
hablar con sus padres sobre todas esas
cosas no empecé mi transición hasta que
tenía 32 y no me abrí con mi padre hasta
que tuve 33
bueno yo vengo de una familia muy
conservadora pero nunca quise perder a
mi padre
cuando te das cuenta de que puedes
perder a quien amas es muy difícil ya
saben tomar esa decisión
apoyaría a mi hijo si fuese trans
cada persona que nace en este planeta es
especial y es afortunado de vivir tienen
la oportunidad de experimentar su vida y
el amor no los influenciar de tal modo
como no esta es la forma en la que debes
vivir debe ser así pero siempre daré
opciones que considero correctas y que
sean cuidadosos con lo que deciden
porque hay implicaciones sociales cosas
que enfrentar lo harían creo que
aceptación y apoyo son dos cosas
distintas al no estar de acuerdo los
seguiría amando estaré allí para ellos
conversaremos sobre eso sí pero estaré
de acuerdo no verás luche mucho con la
aceptación por mucho tiempo y fue muy
duro porque mi mamá me aceptó solo
porque fue ella quien me dio a luz bien
pero si no lo hubiera hecho sería un no
rotundo para mi sabes y odie esa
sensación si yo hubiese crecido en un
lugar donde me sintiera querida y
aceptada incondicionalmente me hubiese
ahorrado años y años de terapia y
psicología de aceptación pero son cosas
que no sabemos en cierto
y lo mejor que podemos hacer es seguir
luchando creo que a pesar de nuestras
diferencias
sentimos lo mismo en el punto de que la
familia es importante al igual que el
amor ser apoyado y amado no importa lo
que pienses muchas veces este mundo nos
puede dañar mucho por eso para mí la
familia es importante y es hermoso que
nos esforcemos para que nuestros hijos
crezcan en un ambiente de amor y respeto
para todos
excelente final
muchas gracias muchas gracias
hermosas muy hermosas
jubilee vive intensamente